is breaking news that's been long
awaited by british travelers because of
course u.s travelers can come into the
uk but it's not reciprocated this could
change and very soon yeah very soon
we're not sure exactly when but uh
within weeks we're told as you say for
18 months brits have not been able to go
to america um more recently that
americans have been able to travel here
to the annoyance i think of many brits
who'd like to go to america so this has
been the forefront of those british
travelers and european travelers who
want to go to america and have been
unable to do so it seems sort of
choreographed as part of the un general
assembly
um maneuvering that's going on the
meetings between biden and johnson that
we're going to see later on this week
and between other european leaders and
the president the americans have agreed
that vaccinated uh people so it's it's
not everybody but those who are
vaccinated passengers from the european
union and britain will be allowed to
travel to
the us so they're relaxing travel
restrictions and that's going to be part
of a sort of broader policy for
international travel so we're not
entirely clear when but we think
sometime between now and november within
weeks so more details will sort of be
fleshed out i guess in the coming days
but the key fact is that for british
people and europeans who want to travel
to america as long as you've been double
vaccinated you're going to be able to go
at some point in the in the near future
yeah november being muted at the moment
and america has always said it will
follow the science but it left people
scratching their heads in terms of
europe nobody from europe could go into
america without a special visa yet
people from caribbean countries and
other south american countries could go
in where there is no vaccination program
so a lot of people found america's
explanation uh you know a bit baffling
what do you think has changed yeah i
think that's part of the legacy of the
during the trump years uh towards the
end of the trump presidency um he made a
fair amount of the fact that he was
concerned about europeans coming there's
a lot of concern about the delta variant
about the uk variant the kent variant i
think the americans have been suspicious
as a as a public as a people not just
the politicians but i think nationally
they've been concerned about what come
might come across the atlantic from
europe so i think it's taken a while to
sort of deal with that resistance about
this um but the americans will say this
is down to the application of cold hard
scientific analysis and that they now
feel that europeans are safe uh they can
travel to america as long as they've
been vaccinated
and that poses no real risk to americans
i think it also shows us a greater
confidence amongst americans because
their vaccination program has been more
sort of bullish than our own you can
walk into a chemist or pharmacist in
america and get your vaccines so as long
as you're rich enough to do that they
got vaccinated before we did so i think
there's a growing sort of i guess more
relaxed approach to vaccinated travelers
coming to america but as you said there
was that kind of dissonance between
those who were vaccinated and those
allowed from other countries for
whatever reason without vaccinations
that now is sort of being balanced out
and it looks like that uh british and
european nationals can go there as long
as they've had both vaccines